Hello Freak bitches.
What,
what about protein?
When you were,
um,
being a Vegan,
what did you,
uh,
did you use like pea protein or a hemp protein?
Like what kind of protein from him?
Because um,
uh,
they test for,
for,
for weed and they said sometimes,
I don't know.
I didn't want it to,
I didn't want to take the chance.
I didn't,
I'm not well versed on what is and what is not.
I know some honest shit that doesn't test positive done.
So I could do whatever I want,
but I don't know why they would say that.
Because most if you get good hamp,
it's not my,
I guess that's the thing is good.
That's what they said.
They seen him,
they said flax seeds can make your tests positive.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
poppy seeds can make this test positive for heroin.
I'm not crazy.
Yeah.
Like people have tested positive on those random drug test to give people their
jobs from having a poppy seed Bagel.
Mama,
you're shooting heroin.
Why me in the fucking Bagel Sandwich?
But anyway,
the NFL like they need to,
um,
uh,
let,
let guys use a weed for oh pain.
Oh for sure.
It's ridiculous.
Well definitely CBDS for sure cause it's not even [inaudible] CBD is just an oil
that comes from a,
comes from hemp plant that's not psychoactive.
My rent.
It's really good for you too.
It was super good for inflammation and joint pain and things along those lines.
Matter of fact,
when I had my,
um,
we actually,
we are some right here.
I'll sit right here.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
This is a Charlotte's web.
This is actually one of my sponsors now.
They make a hemp oil.
I,
yeah,
I didn't mean to apply.
I'm going to do it.
It's actually on this podcast.
I have to do a sponsor about it.
But stuff is great and you just take it and it's drops.
It's good for you.
A negative effects.
When I had my back surgery and um,
2014 at 13.
And uh,
what did you have done?
L Five s one.
I had a discectomy.
Dissectomy yeah.
Um,
they,
uh,
they prescribed Percocet.
Right.
And Percocet.
I used to,
I used to take him for everything else.
They used to make me gag and throw up every single time I took him.
And so really any painkiller that was heavily,
heavily sedate you,
I would always like throw up.
And they told me that if you like have a gag reflex too much that you could
read,
I could have really slipped my disc.
Really.
So for like two days,
I was just like in pain after the surgery and my dad was like,
man,
go get some weed or always,
I'm gonna go get you some weed.
I was like,
wow,
her pot.
He's like,
yeah man.
So he went to the,
and lucky that I was in la,
I got it.
And it had to dispense her.
And so,
uh,
got some and uh,
it helps immediately and I was like,
there's no way that they shouldn't be okay.
It's totally be lyrical events.
We're being [inaudible] being fucked,
you know?
I mean,
it's slowly but surely it's starting to become legal recreationally.
It's legal now in California recreationally.
But the federal government is still resisting it because of the influence of the
pharmaceutical companies and also a bunch of other people that like the prison
guard unions,
they don't want it to be legal cause they,
they would have less people to arrest.
It's kind of fucked up.
Yeah.
No,
the prison industrial complex is a real thing.
They're making money off people being in cages.
It's like there people are human batteries and you get money off of them.
It is the matrix.
It really is.
It's like a very low level version of the matrix.
But it's terrifying if that logic with all the science that's in place about
what's dangerous and what's not.
They're prescribing Percocet.
So like here Fella,
take these.
It makes no sense.
You young strapping buck.
Why don't you take some shit that might get you hooked to have this,
they have this,
this waiver we have to sign.
So there's this,
um,
it just painkiller called Toradol,
Indiana for right.
Yeah.
It's awful.
But I took it a lot because we scrapped that shit to my dog.
Yeah,
she's great with dog.
Got Bit so like,
so for Toyota we have to,
we have to sign this waiver that says you're kind of just giving up your,
it's not,
we're not responsible for it,
but like they'll let us take that but they won't let us smoke weed and they're
abandoned dudes that smoke weed and they're suspended dude's as claims,
right.
He retired because of even just,
um,
I think his name's Josh Gordon.
He played receiver for the browns.
He's one of the best young receivers I've seen in a long time.
But he,
they banned him for a year cause he tested positive.
That's two or three times and it's like you're throwing away,
I mean like granted he needs to be smarter but like you're throwing away an
entire mass career because of weed.
Like it's not crack.
It's not coke.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like it's trying to send a message to the youth to stay away from the
illegal drugs.
He's reg Reagan all over again.
You trying to rule off of fear.
It's fear,
man.
Like not based on reality.
The reality is if you were to legalize drugs,
period,
you can regulate it and that way you can do it in a controlled environment.
And that way you don't have all of this.
I mean that's what they do with the Prohibition of alcohol.
Right.
Legalize it.
Well,
that's also what they're doing right now with a opiate pills.
I mean oxycontin's are now illegal.
They can be prescribed.
You just have to have a doctor that prescribes it.
It's ridiculous.
It is pretty crazy.
Well,
it's really crazy when people realize that marijuana helps pain relief as much,
if not better than all that stuff.
And it doesn't have any of the addictive properties.
And if you do,
there have been people that have said that it's addictive and there's some
studies that pointed that in certain individuals,
but I would state that those people are probably addicted to fucking everything.
I couldn't,
I just don't call it physically.
I don't get how marijuana is addictive.
It just doesn't make any sense.
I've smoked pot every day for years and then I'll take like a month off and
nothing,
not an acre.
Not a pain.
Not a,
no shakes,
no nothing.
You just don't have it.
It's like,
drink orange juice then don't drink large shoes.
No,
it's really nothing there.
Nothing happens.
I'll get it,
man.
I was,
I'm,
I'm not like a heavy smoker like that,
but like,
I'm like a,
uh,
I had on a Saturday night when I ain't going nowhere,
I'm all set up my pipe and my,
and my sack,
and I'm going to watch a great movie.
Why not fall asleep?
Yeah.
What the fuck is wrong with that?
I don't get it,
man.
And meanwhile,
you can get percocets or get drunk as hell and ruin your liver.
Yeah.
[inaudible].